(audience applauds)
- I mean, they're very nice,
this nice audience.
- They are!
I know, they're lovely,
- Thank you.
- They've got a lot of energy,
I was tired this morning,
thank you for that.
(audience applauds)
- I like it, it's a really,
you've got a great show
and everybody's really young and fun and.
- Yeah, okay, I don't know
if we're all young, but yeah.
- Thank you, thank you.
(all laughs)
- I know I haven't put yogurt on today.
(audience applauds)
- Well, I have to say we all know that,
and Great Britain lost Queen Elizabeth.
- [Sarah] Oh.
- So, and that was last year.
So, what are some of
your fondest memories?
- Well, actually right
now, it would be that
in coming towards the
end, she never was able
to walk her doggies, her corgis.
- Yeah.
(audience groans sadly)
- And so, I know it's so sad.
And I used to go into the favorite place
where she used to walk and take a video,
and say, oh, and you'd love this,
look, the magnolia's coming
out and the snow drops are out
(audience coos)
and the primroses are out.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- And so, and I just did
that walk before I came here,
and I got really teared up actually,
because I thought, oh,
I'll just send it to her.
Oh no, she's not there.
And she was such an
extraordinary lady.
- That's the thing
with people passing,
you're like it hits you at weird times.
- Yeah, but one of the
things she'd say now,
to me, to come on this show,
she'd say, "Go on, get out
there, keep being yourself."
That's what she always used
to say to me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think, think that's the secret
why I just keep coming back
rather like a, I don't know,
something you put on flowers,
(audience applauds)
I just keep coming back.
I was gonna say something
else and stopped.
- Is this true that you and Princess Di
once dressed as policewomen?
Like for a, was it a bachelorette party?
- Well, it was my hen
party actually, 1986.
- [Kelly] OK, oh, is that what
you call them hen parties?
- [Sarah] Yes.
- [Kelly] (laughs) I love
that, I didn't know that.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love this!
- But you know, it was extraordinary,
because we went to a nightclub.
Of course you go to a nightclub
with the Princess of Wales,
then Princess of Wales.
And I was just still
Fergie, wasn't married yet.
And we went into this
nightclub and she was very good
as her costume.
Anyway, so we sat down (chuckles),
and the waiter came up to
us and said, "Excuse me,
this is a member's club and it's for fun,
and we don't serve police officers here."
(audience laugh)
Looking straight at us.
- They thought you were real
police officers, A.
- Yes.
- And then two, they
kicked police officers out.
- Yes, and we went out and
as we came out of the stairs,
a lady was getting out of a cab,
and Diana said, "She's got my dress on."
I said, "Dutch!", I called her Dutch.
I said, "Dutch, no, no,
no, you can't say that,
we're meant to be police officers."
It was very funny, and then we were.
- Keep in character!
(all laugh)
- But Kelly, we were then arrested.
- I missed this story, what?
- We were arrested by Parks police.
So we got in the back of the van.
- What did you do to get arrested?
- She had put her engagement
ring round the other way,
and I put mine round the other way.
And we were sitting in there like this,
and she just looked around and
saw a smokey bacon flavored
crisps and started taking
them and eating them,
and the policeman in the front
said, "You can't do that."
We were.
- Just Did.
- Just did
- [Kelly] Just did.
- Yeah, and then eventually they realized
that it was Diana and me.
- But wait, why did y'all get arrested?
- Oh, well 'cause we were
impersonating police officers.
(all laugh)
- [Kelly] Oh my god, people
are allowed to be in costume.
- Hello?
- Yeah.
- Anyway, but.
- Uh, hello?
(all laugh)
- I'm in jury.
- I love you, that's incredible.
- Incredible.
- Oh my god.
- And of course, everyone
always says to me,
but you must miss Dutch, you and Diana.
And I go, no, 'cause I
mean, she's with me all day.
'Cause she's the only one who really,
she and I, we laughed a lot.
We got into trouble a lot.
And then she used to, do you
know what she used to do?
She used to tell me the
worst story, joke story
just before I had to be serious.
(all laugh)
So I'd go straight in to
dinner, and she'd always,
'cause she'd been there
a few years before me.
She used to run like a gazelle
to get into the dining room
quicker than me.
And I now I thought, well
that's a bit strange.
And when I got in I realized why,
'cause she got the young people,
and I got all the old people.
- A clever one.
So wait, your new book,
let's talk about it.
- [Sarah] Oh yes.
- So it's called "A Most Intriguing Lady".
- [Sarah] Yes.
- So why did you, this is book two, is it?
- Yes, book two.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Just very quickly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause I know you're so busy.
I honestly, the British
newspapers and various newspapers
around the world always like, I dunno why,
they just love bad Fergie,
sells a lot of papers.
(all laugh)
- So I'm excited, I decided
that I'm still alive,
actually miracle, right?
So I thought that I
ought to really work out,
it must be my red-headed
gene, that I was born
with bright red, a bath hat of red curls.
I mean, what a joke, really?
- Or beautiful.
- Well, I researched all the redheads
and I believe every
woman, of course, and men,
but should be given a voice,
and be respected and allowed
to be themselves, not judged.
And I feel really strongly
that I then went back
into my ancestors and I found two redheads
that have been in the grave,
and they'd all written
about the brothers but not about them.
And that were my aunt, my
great-aunt, this is my great-aunt.
- Oh wow.
- And so I took her outta
the grave and I said,
come on darling, you are fabulous.
Let's make a story about
you 'cause I'm alive
and you are my ancestor,
so I'm gonna write a novel,
but it's based on me, really.
- Yeah, I love that.
- [Sarah] And also, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- It's fun, yeah, (laughs) oh my God.
- And also, guess what?
I actually, yeah, you can
star in it, we'll cast you.
- Please, I would love
to, I do a great accent.
- And you can sing the theme song.
- Yeah, I was like, don't ask me to act.
- But what I love about this book,
is that it's during the
day, she's very proper
and a lady, and everybody is.
it's sort of Cary Grant "To
Catch a Thief" type bit.
Yeah, and at night she
turns into a crimes,
a solving crimes.
- [Kelly] Kinda like a detective.
- She's a female detective!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Yeah, I love this.
- And so it's very most intriguing.
Yeah, you'll like it.
- I like a mystery, I like, yeah.
- I do too.
- It's very sort of.
- I didn't used to, but like lately,
the past sort of five years
I'm like really into it.
- [Sarah] Yep, I love it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Sarah] I love it.
- Okay, we have to do another
commercial break, y'all.
But the Duchess's book is
called "A Most Intriguing Lady".
It's out now.